mighty number nine might not bear the
megaman name but there's no escaping the
fact that it's a spiritual successor of
the classic side-scrolling series you
run jump and shoot it any robots through
a series of 2d levels and for every boss
you defeat you gained a new ability to
use during the rest of your journey
that's not to mention longtime Megaman
producer Keiji Inafune a is at the helm
there's more to money number nine than
elements of just Megaman however you're
encouraged to be fast and efficient you
could argue this is just a reflection of
the Megaman X Games where skillful
dashing was required in order to
complete certain levels or reach secret
areas but money number nine rewards
quick and nimble play in a new way
by allowing you to absorb particles from
damaged enemies that temporarily enhance
your speed armor and power these boosts
have an immediate and tangible effect
and the more you play the more skilled
you become with both acquiring and using
them money number nine sense of speed
evokes intermittent exhilaration and his
systolic elements can you charm it but
these spurts of joy aren't enough to
carry a game in the face of its standout
issues
there are a total of 12 stages to
complete in story mode before that you
unlock after you finish the initial 8
these 8 levels can be tackled in any
order you wish but don't mistake this
open-ended level selection as a true
call back to Mega Man's punishing
structure where you once had to decipher
the correct path through stages and
ultimately bosses money number nines
bosses can all be defeated using your
default weapon with reasonable effort
unless you rarely feel compelled to
explore your weapon upgrades the last 4
stages are an exception where obstacles
in particular demand the use of one
weapon or another but at that point you
have no attachment to your newfound
tools and thus only a vague sense of
pride in your progress
the real challenge lies in earning high
ranks killing groups of enemies in a
specific way that earns e accolades is
an ever-present challenge marks are
determined by factors like how much
damage you take how many enemies you
kill and how efficient you are tubes
orbing their energy perfecting your
reflexes is a fun pursuit if only
because of the rewarding feelings you
get from chaining together attacks and
dashes in a fast and stylish manner but
it's nothing more than a convenient way
to spice up money number 9s typical
action
at best the games 3d models look like
sharp and expressive recreations of
classic game art but mighty number 9 s
presentation mostly feels like a
compromised effort failing to deliver
either contemporary Flair or classic
whimsy cutscenes are particularly
disappointing but characters that simply
sway in place as they talk through
static mouths
you can choose to hear dialog in either
Japanese or English but expect to switch
to Japanese regardless of your habitual
preference the English voice acting is
too slow and abrasive to stomach the
Japanese government won't let us
intervene until we know the cause of the
malfunctions hmm I was afraid of that
but it makes sense after all any robots
you send to help could be affected as
well making things even worse for a game
that's meant to bear the legacy of a
classic series mighty number 9 barely
succeeds it may rouse excitement from
time to time but by and large it lacks a
pervading sense of artistry both in its
level design and presentation mighty
number 9 is an inoffensive ly average
game sprung from the memories of the
past with little to show for its
position in the present
for